[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by cash up as you know
cash up is the simplest way to send and
save money and now it's the simplest way
to try and grow your money with cash up
investing I use it to pay people back
for dinner
I use it to pay people to hang out with
me because I'm truly adore on the inside
I pay 2 mm for inviting me to a studio
just kidding then that was a joke you
but anyway you use cash app to invest in
any stock for as little as $1 you hear
me
brokerage services are provided by cash
up investing a subsidiary of square and
member si PC and as always when you sign
up for cash up and use the promo code
Congrats not only will you instantly
receive $10 but cash up will also now
donate $10 to the trevor project an
amazing organization that provides
crisis intervention and suicide
prevention services to LGBTQ youth
across America download cash app from
the App Store or Google Play Store today
[Music]
well that's like that my babies it's
episode 156 and dude it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
than it's ever been dude it keeps
leveling up and we keep doubling and we
keep doubling it until the kill me yeah
Tupac laughs like my uncle Richard
anyway January coming up going to Irvine
California and dude let me tell you
something it sold out my babies it is
sold out and it sold out long time ago
cuz your boy keeps level and up your boy
keeps catching heat your boy that's how
we're going all the way to Irvine back
in it we'll go we're driving backwards
it's not my fault dude it's not my fault
you guys made this happen you guys made
this happen
so yeah dude I went to I went to what do
you call it I don't I don't know I saw
those I start sentences and it's not an
ed and it's not even the sentence I want
to so I figure out the sentence later
I'm good under pressure you understand
these sunglasses I don't know how I got
them but we don't need them do it's all
good my babies but I'll tell you this
I'm going to Irvine that's all sold out
so it's it's yeah but we're adding
another Irvine date they were like do
you want to do add more shows and I was
like bro you're gonna try to give me a
heart attack man I know I'm the youngest
man alive but you're gonna try and
[ __ ] you know put atom or D I got to
do eight shows for the weekend so I'm
just gonna do it later on in the summer
so ever find B where Pasadena Ice House
I think it's probably sold out West Palm
Beach Florida who the [ __ ] knows but
March 20th and March 21st are we gonna
add more shows who knows
Robinson Ville Mississippi why is it a
place interesting and interestingly
enough it's a place and I'll be playing
the Horseshoe Casino in hotel so go get
tickets at Chris D'Elia calm Rohnert
Park California where is it grant and
Resort Casino and then Las Vegas I got
two gigs coming up in Las Vegas and then
Brea California we just added two
weekends in a row who the [ __ ] am i jo
koy I got a star
doing [ __ ] Instagram videos like this
that's what jo koy does anyway dude we
got up here some artwork that somebody
made from a pig every now and then I'll
take a picture that I think it's funny
I'll post online and then I wish I never
took the [ __ ] picture in my life and
this is one of those pictures I took
and somebody photoshopped it and then
somebody painted it and gave it to me
and my [ __ ] Orillia shows so I did
that and and that's that's that and I
got the know kuda chain and then he
koude under it but that I got that I
think in Ohio yes I got it in Ohio
anyway I was in Orillia and it was a
little bit on and poppin but also a
little bit cold as [ __ ] and it was so be
so beautiful the [ __ ] in the snow I
never seen snow like that except for
when I was a young pup in New Jersey and
I was a young pup in New Jersey do it
but here's the thing
before I even get into what happened
this weekend and everything like that
your boy got [ __ ] for real not lyin
I'm not doing it like a [ __ ] white
chick that eat sushi too much I am
telling you the truth your boy got over
12 hours of sleep [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Music]
twelve hours of sleep you know how you
wake up after twelve twelve twelve hours
of sleep you wake up like this oh and
then you do your day dude and you do
your day and it's and you don't really
do much because you're just chilling and
you work hard all weekend but you're
doing your day dude and nobody even even
if someone's rude to you you're just
like hahahaha turn your [ __ ] back and
you just walk away
positivity man you think I didn't watch
that [ __ ] documentary on Hulu jawline
oh I saw it
that kid preaches processed positivity
he's like a fifteen year old that
preaches preaches positivity
hey let's say preaches not peaches twice
in a row but dude he preaches positivity
and he's 15 years old he doesn't know
what the [ __ ] he's saying because he's
15 and when he's 30 let's hope that he
[ __ ] liked what he was doing when he
was 15 because everybody is we're being
recorded now as a kid I grew up and I'm
happy the [ __ ] place I grew up
because nobody was recording me at 15
and 16 because bro I don't even like the
[ __ ] I did when I was 31
but that documentary is [ __ ] crazy
dude jawline I only watched half of it
my buddy Kevin Christie turned me on to
it and I watched a little bit of it you
gotta watch this [ __ ] man it's so odd
man these kids start posting on
something called you now and they did
get followers and the kids just like on
to be famous because then I could do
good for the world and it's weird this
the the kid is literally a child version
of Mark Wahlberg from Boogie Nights
anyway
anyway what was I talking about I threw
so many [ __ ] logs into the fire and
I'm trying to irons in the fire what
sleep and then after that was one of the
logs I throw in a fire I was trying to
talk about something bigger
who knows dude but I was I was talking
about going Orillia oh go on really I
went to really I got twelve hours of
sleep I didn't get much sleep the night
before because the walls are thin in
Orillia and it was beautiful dude the
snow was beautiful
but I got home got 12 hours of sleep now
it's today when I went here's the thing
when I went to Orillia and this is
[ __ ] so oh by the way when I was in
Orillia I should say I'm wearing I am
wearing I brought life is about change
life is about complete change life is
about growing as a person and life is
about sometimes not being so stick stuck
to your guns that we make some amends
and we make a set what do you call them
exceptions to the rules now your boys
not better than that your boys not
better than that you got to make
exceptions to the rules if you don't
make exceptions to the rules you're a
[ __ ] annoying actor piece of [ __ ]
even if you're in the middle of [ __ ]
Dayton or you're down in you know
Alabama
you're still in an annoying actor piece
of [ __ ] I used to have a buddy that
would stick to his diet and whenever
like we were on vacation we would have a
pizza
he'd be like nod just get me a salad boy
you're an annoying actor piece of [ __ ]
did you know that you're an annoying
actor piece of [ __ ] take a piece of
pizza put it in your goddamn mouth who
gives a [ __ ] okay every role every role
you're playing is shredded by the way he
was playing sixteen year olds his 60
he was a [ __ ] 38 year old putting
sixteen year olds you don't need to be
shredded to play someone's son haha
so your boy is wearing a jersey why hold
on a second that meme of the guy
blinking his eyes just like the blond
guy your boys wear to Jersey why your
boys not into sports if you saw
incorrigible you know my bid on sports
now yeah granted you're looking at me
and you're like okay so he's sure so
what's going on why is he shooting in in
the car in Colorado hey why is your kid
in Boulder why is the key why is your
kid and why is he in [ __ ] Colorado
Springs
he's not dude I'm in the studio and
these are my shoulders yeah it looks
like [ __ ] you might take a ski lift
on him right because they they [ __ ]
pop they go wide bro I'm not even
[ __ ] around they go why
alright alright okay sometimes I walk
through doors sideways and I get it I
don't have to but I do it just in case
alright cuz I don't want to [ __ ]
scrape the shit's out the sides of my
shoulders anyway I've got this Toronto
Raptors [ __ ] Jersey on because they
won last year at the NBA Finals chips
with the dip remember Drake so these
guys my Bloods Curtis [ __ ] Lee look
at his last name here who knows they're
there they're fans of the podcast and
they came to my show let me [ __ ] text
them right now so it pops up can't stay
at Curtis Diggins and on Instagram see
Diggins peed ov and Alan Regan Nike
Toronto made me this [ __ ] Jersey it's
not just any Jersey dude thank you for
the people at Nike Toronto but bro check
this out zero dents dude that's the
numbers zero and for the name for those
you listening dents and also that's my
[ __ ] tricep and my [ __ ] shoulders
do it what the [ __ ] what am i a genie
coming out of a bottle dude I'll tell
you what man that's what's up so now
we're Jersey and I'm gonna work out on
this today and and people gonna look at
me like that wee-bey meme anyway dude
it's all good so I got this Jersey and
that's so cool dude did you know that's
cool
so went to Orillia now here's the deal
my opener who's gonna remain nameless
now because he doesn't deserve the
credit at this point okay because let me
show you how pissed I am if you could
imagine how pissed I am so he was I said
hey we've got it we've got two gigs in
oh really a Canada he says where's that
I say two hours from Toronto and he goes
cool I love Toronto and I think well
it's not Toronto so we so he says hey by
the way I have a gig two days before
the Toronto gig and it's in Chicago now
I bring an opener because a lot of the
time I've met one of the main reasons I
bring an opener is because I like to
travel with somebody I don't like to be
if I'm a [ __ ] lonely boy dude if I
take flights across the country if I
take internet intercontinental or just
continental flights I'm a lonely boy if
I'm alone you know you understand
i buy cashews at the [ __ ] Hudson news
and I'm eating them like I want him but
I don't want them I get salted almonds
right but I'm a lonely boy I eat them
like I'm [ __ ] Oliver Twist asking Met
Police have more or whatever the [ __ ]
that was I'm a lonely boy I'm just
eating because I'm a lonely boy but if I
have [ __ ] mic whoops if I have my
opener with me I don't need to get those
things because I'm not feeling insecure
and I'm not a lonely boy okay so he says
look I know you like to bring me because
you like to pay me and you like to and
you like to pay me for free for you not
being a lonely boy and I say okay yeah
what's coming and he says well it just
so turns out that I have a gig two days
before in Chicago do you think that I
could fly to Chicago and then the next
day I could fly to Toronto since it's so
close and meet you in Toronto and I say
you know what sure yeah of course I'll
take the [ __ ] lonely boy flight so I
take the lonely boy flight and he says
the day before right but the day before
the [ __ ] lonely boy flight right he
says hey don't be mad and I go like this
too late okay because if you're saying
hey don't be mad
I like being mad too much and I'm
already mad so so he says and if you
know anything about my opener already
you know he's a dingus piece of [ __ ] all
right
so and you know he's [ __ ] not it he's
pretty [ __ ] dumb like he's in his
life he's gone like this before
duh you know and so he says to me I
figured it out already
dude that's
Beth yay dude it's so awesome that he
goes like this don't be mad I figured it
out already they say hey don't be mad I
figured it out already now there's a
certain level of madness I get when that
happens I want you to know about the
levels of Matt first of all there's
annoyed that's not that bad it's like in
a fun territory girl like god damn it
they [ __ ] forgot to catch up whatever
the [ __ ] then there's a level of mad
where you go like this oh [ __ ] bro I'm
[ __ ] mad you tell me what the [ __ ]
going on I'm furious and I'm yelling and
then there's another level of mad on top
of that where you go quiet well you just
sit back and you relax
it's like when the [ __ ] it's like in
the in that when I was watching the show
the movie this one movie where it was
like a world ending movie whatever the
[ __ ] by roland emmerich something called
like deep horizon or impact of the
[ __ ] tomorrow whatever the [ __ ] it
was where the big wave was coming and
the dad and his daughter is like here it
comes and they just hug each other their
karma [ __ ] that's how calm I am I'm
[ __ ] watching this big wave come
crashing and I know everybody's Ariana
okay I'm in a movie I'm in a Roland
Emmerich movie right now when mike says
hey don't be mad I figured it out I grab
my daughter and I wait for that big wave
because what the [ __ ] am I gonna do do
it so so he says no so I say so I this
is what happened he says don't be mad I
figured it out and I say you forgot your
passport and he says okay yeah my
waiting for that way though was getting
a little bit bigger right
it was far away I said you forgot your
passport and the WIMP that wave got a
little bit bigger it went from there to
there here it comes it's getting louder
and he says so you know how I always
bring my passport card with me and if
you're an avid listener of
congratulations podcast
you know that Mike brought that once to
try and get over the border that's
something HAP I don't remember what the
[ __ ] happened you remember the episode
something happened where he had to the
[ __ ] passport and we were like oh it
doesn't work for the flight but we're
driving over anyway so it's okay
I was like a better [ __ ] work and it
did work and he was like yeah and I was
like all right you won luckily dude you
had [ __ ] 19 and you hit and you got
it too but you're lucky you should have
kept the 19 I don't like when [ __ ] works
out for dummies so you understand you
need to understand that you're a dumb
[ __ ] and have the [ __ ] happen and that's
it dude you deal with it and that's how
you learn and if you're 35 like he is so
bad so so he says I have that cuz I
always have it because my mom made me
get it dude his dick is probably [ __ ]
four and a half inches and when it gets
hard it's probably four inches Jenna
Stan his dick [ __ ] doesn't even get
bigger it congeals it like gets smaller
but harder so anyway so he says some
luckily my mom made me get my peg dude
okay so he goes like this so here's what
I'm gonna do
and that wave got a little bit bigger
the wave the wave wait a second I'm
squinting my eyes did it double inside
did it double in size so I grab my
daughter a little harder and I pull her
in because maybe this is the big one and
he says I'm gonna take a flight from
Chicago to Buffalo New York wait a
second did that wave get a little bit
bigger
my daughter puts her [ __ ] chin into
daddy's shoulder okay so I say uh-huh
and he says I'm gonna have
I'm gonna fly into Buffalo really early
and then I'm gonna have someone hey dude
let me tell you something let's let's
let's cut back it's like one of those
movies that begins and runs like and the
guys like summed like that movie with
[ __ ] Chris burns well what's that
guy's name is that know Chris head burns
and he and it starts and he and he's
dead and he says so I'm dead right and
then it goes Wow and it flashes back
here like I gotta find out how this
[ __ ] guy died or American Beauty when
he's like this is the last day of my
life you know like I we gotta find out
what the [ __ ] happens he's dead by the
end of this that's what happens he says
so so let's cut back all the way back
hey when you're saying don't be mad I
figured it out in no part of the rest of
that conversation do you say the word
someone you understand because if you
figured it out you know who all right so
that wave what I'm noticing it's getting
real white at the top which means it's
curling over its not gonna subside so I
say yeah he says someone's gonna pick
someone's gonna pick me up in Buffalo
and bring me to the Toronto Airport
while I use my passport card to get over
the border and I'll meet you when you
land and I can tell he's nervous but
what I can tell even more is that wave
is gonna kill us
my daughter's crying at this point okay
so I go like this
okay and I hang up cuz your boy means
business I don't hang up lately I hang
up heavily
so say Kay the day comes where he hits
me up by the way how far is it from
Buffalo two hours and five minutes
Wow it's [ __ ] a hundred miles this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know so the day comes
hi yada-yada I'm taking this in that a
train he took a train he took every
[ __ ] window he took a train a plane a
[ __ ] car this guy I expected him a
half expect him to show up with a
[ __ ] or and shorts on and I get to
the thing my flights delayed I get in at
1:00 a.m. and he's sitting there and
he's like bro I'm so tired and I look at
him and I go good and I realized that
wave and my daughter it didn't exist
because it was all a movie it was
directed by Roland Emmerich it wasn't
real life he made it happen but he
learned and the thing about that is he
didn't learn he'll do it again
but in that brief moment of time he
learned and I didn't even really get
that pissed because there was no reason
to I was either gonna have an opener I
said hey man you tell Andrew my agent
maja powered agent I was like you tell
Andrew to [ __ ] make sure to get
another opener on deck because bro I'm
not doing it alone and he was like no
don't worry about it and I was like I
said you know how madam be if there's no
opener right and he stood you up anyway
wow dude you know that honey is the free
online shopping tool that automatically
finds the best promo codes and applies
them to your cart and you know how great
it feels to save but how does it feel
how does it feel to save with honey
saving with honey feels like sliding
into a seat on the train just before the
doors closed
that's like that's what I call that my
[ __ ] anoche hitting every green light on
your commute commute
finishing up your podcast episode right
as you walk into work uh that's for you
not me because Marcus is my work but
honey has found it's over 18 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings did you know that honey supports
over 30,000 stores online including
Macy's targets of
for a best buy and more and they're
adding more everyday users love honey
and that's why it has over 100 thousand
five five star reviews on the Google
Chrome store Juan just bought me a bunch
of stuff for the pod room on Amazon and
it saved
what was that forty nine dollars without
using anything extra thanks honey
dude forty nine dollars that's two
lunches using honey feels pretty great
think of it as a little daily victory
plus because that's how I do it when I
go through my day I'm like I won I won I
won when are you selling I'm like I won
or if I just think that doesn't work I
lost but with honey I want plus it's
free to use and installs in just a few
seconds get honey for free at join
honeycomb slash Congrats that's join
honeycomb slash / congrats quip used it
today quip makers uh equip makers of the
quip electric toothbrush want you to
know that one single discovery matters
most for your dental care it's simply
this that if you have good habits you
are good
that means brushing for two minutes
twice a day and flossing regularly no
matter what brand you use quip makes
that simple starting with an electric
toothbrush refillable floss and anti
cavity toothpaste quick quips electric
brush has sensitive sonic vibrations
with a built-in timer and 30-second
pulses to guide a full and even clean
the quip floss dispenser comes with
pre-marked string to help you use just
enough plus quip delivers fresh brush
head floss and toothpaste refills to
your door every three months with free
shipping so your routine is always right
join over 3 million healthy mouth and
get clipped today starting at $25 what
you probably like well I've got it cost
forty five grand right no you probably
okay well then 30 grand what
no $25 okay how is that true because
clip and if you go to get quip comm /
Congrats right now you'll get your first
refill free
that's your first refill free at get
quip comm / Congrats
spelled GE t qu IP dot-com / congrats
quip the good habits company um nice
baby nice we went to Canada uh you know
what's [ __ ] annoying is Tom Segura is
like Spanish now you know he's doing a
[ __ ] Spanish podcast
this guy's got all the podcasts and now
he's gonna be Spanish - dude guys
shorten another language he's like the
[ __ ] who's that guy pylons let the
music feel the rhythm bailamos Marc
Anthony or whatever is that Rick Enrique
Iglesias Rick Ricky Martin or Enrique
Iglesias [ __ ] whoever it is do it I
gotta learn Japanese do it Enrique
Iglesias
bailamos let the rhythm take you over by
the moss I don't like when [ __ ] songs
go in between languages have a language
in a song and stick to that [ __ ] song
you know what I mean it's not like
people are like and the shark bites
don't you get it I don't indigo their
younger begins they order huh pearly
whites
[Applause]
[Laughter]
why don't they they only they
legitimately only do that with Spanish
they got to do that with Japanese they
got to do it with Danish they got to do
it with [ __ ] whatever the hell is in
Paris France you know that cool yeah
they got to do that when the shark bites
going to get Moody and they don't do it
because it's a horse [ __ ] attitude of
this song would change it doesn't change
when you do in Spanish bailamos
but if you did it with Japanese you know
the most needy um anyway do it I got to
do a podcast in a different language I
got to do a podcast in a different a
region just [ __ ] become the number
one podcaster and what are they speaking
Denmark or [ __ ] Sweden whether they
speak Swedish who who knows I don't know
anyway dude congrats to Tom Segura
Spanish he's [ __ ] Spanish now
apparently he always knew Spanish I you
know alright dude the guy's taking over
man is [ __ ] I've got he's got so many
podcasts bro I got to get more podcast I
got one all right uh yeah so did you see
that I shall talk about that later but
dude how about the fact that that you
guys watching that Aaron Hernandez
document documentary on Netflix
looks like Brendan Schaub right it's
crazy
looks like Brendan Schaub but like if
Brendan Schaub like kind of like well I
don't know if you cared about his
appearance less but he's also handsome I
must say he's less handsome than Brendan
Schaub he's probably both - probably
both the same but god there's a real
sociopath huh I watched it people ruin
[ __ ] by saying oh it's [ __ ] amazing
they just want to be on the train it is
good but the third episode is the one
that really is good the first two
episodes sure I'm along for the ride but
the third episode is really what [ __ ]
took it for me like it's all about how
he had it like they you know the way the
documentary did it was like he couldn't
live his real life and it really
bothered him and it was like a cocktail
of [ __ ] emotional activity that just
made him act like a tough guy and kill
people because he was like a closeted
homosexual
and he couldn't deal with it and
apparently the other dude that he killed
was gonna out him and so he killed them
that's what the the documentary made it
made it kind of seemed makes it kind of
seemed like which is [ __ ] so wild I
just like every now and then I'll stop
and I'll think about like imagine
killing someone like um I'm telling you
right now this what I'm telling you
right now this is Chris D'Elia and I
know there's a pop comedy podcast and I
do lots of beat bits
some of them funny most of them that but
I'm telling you it neither you know the
more than awesome run funnyman they're
putting in there but like I'm saying is
if if i if i'm ever accused of killing
someone I'm telling you straight up I
was framed
okay like for real if my Bloods at the
scene if their semen somewhere if some
of my hairs on a dresser caught in
between one of the [ __ ] doors someone
put it there okay I didn't do it I'm not
killing anyone ever that's my promise I
was framed not saying I can't
your boys beefy right you boys beef but
dude I didn't do it all right
so I will fight it I will I will about
here's the other thing too they some
about like what was the one where he was
like I saw one of these documentaries
where the guy was like yeah I didn't do
it and they kit and and they found out I
was innocent but something where it was
like they were gonna let me out but I
had to admit it that I did it but I
didn't want to was this the same
documentary or something no it wasn't
but there's some other documentary I was
watching and he was like he was like III
have to admit it I have
to take the the plea but admit that I
did it and he was like I'm not doing
that because that will mean I was always
a convicted murderer and even though
I'll be out in the world
what the [ __ ] documentary was it it was
I can't remember what it was anyway I
must have seen it on Netflix or
something but he [ __ ] straight-up
said no I'm gonna go for broke
and he [ __ ] I see the guy's face
some of you listeners were look good no
it's not the staircase but he was like I
was his like I'm I'm I'm not gonna I'm
gonna go for broke and I don't want it
on my record so he [ __ ] he went to
trial I was like bro if they offer me a
deal hey thanks but thanks but you're a
convicted murderer okay okay
but I'm free he was like I'll never see
my he had a kid too was just a [ __ ]
errand no it wasn't on mixing up I see
so many these murder documentaries dude
I'm surprised I don't go to bed and just
dream of people killing me anyway
I'm sure people will tweet me and I
won't look at it but uh yeah this Aaron
Hernandez thing man I just I just like
imagine first of all how hard it is to
come out as gay but imagine doing it as
a football player and your whole life is
being manly and that's got to be so hard
my heart goes out to anybody coming out
of the closet especially if you have a
family that's not gonna accept you but
even if you do it's [ __ ] hard enough
word up to all my or if I was uh that
happy
Chet Hanks Big Ups follow me gays
because told me closeted gays boyish ah
big up follow me gays everybody hiding
in the closet a move big
they movie on the area big ups foot
creaking that doorway out and walking
out big ups for moving across to the
side and walk and our big ups for coming
out and [ __ ] guys in Europe any area
anyway uh yeah there's so many murder
documentaries is crazy
I got a do a that's what I got to do my
next special I know my I got another one
coming out soon but my next one I got to
do a murder documentary slash comedy
special that [ __ ] would bro I'll be
playing arenas and make Sebastian
Maniscalco look like he's playing up a
mic bro dad believe I would [ __ ] but
boom yeah I should just murdered a
murder documentary comedy special forget
it that's it flying private everywhere I
got one [ __ ] black nail just so as
you know I didn't slam it in a door I
painted them because I had to do this
because I painted him on a [ __ ] show
I did for Netflix for Bert Kreischer
called the cabin and painted one I left
one I took him off and then I left one
but you boys got ink you boys got a
[ __ ] emo finger you boys got a tank
top on and he was wearing sunglasses
earlier bro does he what the [ __ ] I'm
young and I'm this young bro mm-hmm and
I drink like this I don't give up Who am
I yeah I'm not cult leader as Who I am
do it anyway
one time my ex said that when I when I
point my triceps look flabby oh and so
and I should start working out and
that's one of the reasons why I started
working out and now his laughing dude
and now who's laughing oh but your boy
was insecure that day oh but now who's
laughing yeah it's still flabby but that
shit's a [ __ ] mush let's let's weigh
it let's wait let's wait and see if it's
[ __ ] muscle or fat let's weigh
[Laughter]
um how about did you see the [ __ ]
call well it was that guy that does the
hearts on the convert the heart thing
everyone's wearing his heart [ __ ]
think on Dakar song or whatever the [ __ ]
it is what's it [ __ ] how would I even
spell it you know what I mean like comme
des Garcons Conde gar de gar gar gar
song yeah calm calms de garde
you know what combs dick Garson okay
that's what it is
he's always got the heart peaking out of
the [ __ ] bottom of the converse shoe
and chicks wear it like they think it
[ __ ] makes him like like they like
they think it makes them look like they
read that I'm not into that that comme
des Garcons [ __ ] the chicks wear a
[ __ ] that heart how could somebody
have an image like that it's so weird
that somebody could just go for broke on
one image the guys like what is he
French what is that Spanish I don't even
know what that is he's just like yeah I
put the eyes on the house
oh it's he's French but it's made in
Spain cool man hey way too confusing
dude what is this [ __ ] that movie
would Madame kanyi where he's stuck
behind the staircase interstellar uh bro
that movie huh how about that movie are
you stuck by once he was stuck behind a
staircase I was like alright did we
finish our popcorn I love Chris Nolan
bro that guy makes bangers I can't wait
till that [ __ ] timid movie comes out
or whatever the [ __ ] it's called tenant
tenant the [ __ ] is it lieutenant it's
about someone who lives in an apartment
complex it's a bad joke anyway what was
I saying about the [ __ ] thing yeah
about could talk about the cornrows he
made that people wear the white kids
wear the [ __ ] cornrows
what do you cook is it cornrows is that
what it is here it is coned egg our song
criticized for cultural appropriation
using lace front cornrow wigs
hey guy that's one of those things where
it's like yo is this the hell you're
gonna die on because I I would I here's
what would happen
if I was counting our song which I'm not
but hey go away add the first of all
major Japanese fashion label
oh it's Japanese contig our song has
always pushed boundaries by this time
they have but but this time they've gone
too far this is from CNN the branch
showcases men's fall winter 2020 line
this week at Paris Fashion Week a key
part of the runway look amid the bright
colors and cropped jackets appeared to
be lace front cornrow wigs and the
effect is a debatable I love in articles
when they use the word ah because it's
like oh [ __ ] there's being so [ __ ] about
it like a journalist straight up cuz
like journalists the whole thing is like
when a reporter is supposed to not
[ __ ] stutter and when they throw a
stutter in that's the most [ __ ] [ __ ]
hello coming to you live I mean think
about the guy think about that [ __ ] the
Broadway showcase it's men's fall winter
20 20 lines this week in Paris Fashion
Week a key part of the runway look amid
the bright colors and cropped jackets
appear to be lace front cornrow wigs and
the effect is uh debatable I mean dude
with the graphics and chick serving it
in and so anyway here's the thing if I
were doing that someone I in my head I
would be like what we probably shouldn't
do this unless we want to [ __ ] go
double it double up on it and go for
broke and be like your mother [ __ ]
don't get it I'm doing what I want
I'm not cultural appropriation I'm gonna
say this how I am but you go on that
[ __ ] cultural but this guy would have to
not believe maybe like [ __ ] culture
appropriation this isn't that you guys
have [ __ ] you know lefties you guys
lefties but you're gonna get in trouble
for sure and you got to know you're
gonna get in trouble
alright maybe they don't have black
people that work at the company that
much or whatever the [ __ ] but like also
here's the other thing they literally
use the whoo these kids are translucent
do it they're not white they're
translucent
so like to make Anderson Cooper look
like the guy from Amistad so um and not
Matthew McConaughey uh yeah do it I mean
this kid and they're like 18 another Pro
younger now I don't know maybe they're
40 who knows he's [ __ ] mean kid never
- how these models are because they
don't eat and they did but look dear all
this would one of them what the bloody
rights one of the people right so that
that was a stylist my inspiration for
come to Carson show was Egyptian Prince
look I felt really beautiful
informational look at this was an homage
never was a my decision to hurt or
offend anyone ever if I did I deeply
apologize
see that's the weirdest part you didn't
know dude
hey okay qe one of them had hey oh wow
look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] so many
patterns why is just doing all of it the
most artistic you know time talking
about wow fashion sucks do it these guys
weren't a wig out of his shirt looks
like someone ran full speed in a woman
got stuck it's so annoying and all the
patterns he's got a checkered board he's
got flannel pants and then a different
colored checkered [ __ ] vest and a
[ __ ] gold chain with a wig over the
gold chain and also a wig of cornrows on
his hair and black [ __ ] Michael
Jackson shoes
hey dude drive-by single shot comme des
Garcons Yeah right dude what a [ __ ] he
was just like put it all on it's like
well we have all these things left and
we bought them they're gonna go to waste
and he just said put them all on we have
extra wigs hang them over their chest oh
my god dude strong with everyone
blue apron blue apron can healthy be
delicious blue apron and I think so by
the way I've been cooking with this blue
apron and healthy is delicious and this
is healthy and your boys getting lean
and mean go on it with me dude I'm
[ __ ] getting the way I'm getting dude
healthy can be delicious with the new
health-conscious menus featuring a range
of ready to cook meals made with lean
proteins whole grains minimal dairy and
flavor packed Purdue's the year the new
year is looking bright I gotta wear my
sunglasses for this the new year's
looking so bright uh I got one fire son
guys it's all good he's some and it's a
prescription so cool can't see anything
the beginning of a new year is great
time to reevaluate your lifestyle and
eating habits blue apron believes a
healthy lifestyle starts with a balanced
relationship with food and knowing
exactly what goes into each meal because
you chopped grated zested seared
seasoned and plated it to existence all
from the comfort of home create a
personalized plan that works for you at
blue aprons the ever-changing mix of
plant forward vegetarian carb-conscious
mediterranean diabetes friendly WW
approved and five hundred calorie or
less options best of all blue apron
helps me disconnect from my home phone
discover my inner chef and because you
can't look at your phone when you're
cooking you got sauce all over your
hands you know or you got like something
beautiful on your hands like ingredients
that like make that taste really good
forget looking at food on social media
now I'm actually taking the time to
plate my meal and really enjoy a blue
apron is just awesome thank you create a
healthy meal time routine that works for
you in 2020 check out this week's menu
and get sixty dollars off when you visit
blue apron comstock Congrats that's blue
apron calm / Congrats blue apron feed
your soul congratulations is brought to
you by cash up B official app of the log
cabin it's on my babies Wow
I got some weird apps on my phone that
just pop up this app
tells me what's going on in the
neighborhood looking for a good divorce
lawyer it says bro who are my neighbors
living in sin stick it out what are you
[ __ ] what do you want the end of days
stick it out dude stop living in sin
stick it out or go to hell
he said drinking his iced americano like
he does every day and like how he has
every day ever since he was 23
dude one time I mic my buddy told me
what that I used to live with him and he
was like I was like you want to get a
coffee he's like who the [ __ ] goes and
gets coffee why would you go get coffee
that's so weird to just go get coffee
bro and then years later I saw him at a
coffee spot and I drove by and I saw him
there and I was like yeah okay it you
[ __ ] words dude and then I drove away
and that's the end of that quick a
beautiful poignant story some stories
are just real real real real real real
real short like the passport one it was
good it was good and it was long because
I could implement a [ __ ] roland
emmerich film in the middle of it but
some stories are good short like one
time my friend made fun of me for
getting coffee and then years later I
draw drove by and saw him at a coffee
spot and that's that anyway dude that's
[ __ ] the Conn Dekker song and the
[ __ ] things or what's going on in the
world and Prince Harry's leaving the
[ __ ] Royal [ __ ] and it's all good
it's gonna be fine the main thing about
that is it doesn't matter even a little
bit for anybody but we do get a lot of
it and it's okay now are we gonna make a
big deal out of it yes does it matter
no it's about it any of us know does it
even really matter to him and his family
know it doesn't now is his girl going to
make it seem is that we're gonna make it
seem like his girl has tainted the rough
I mean yes did you know it doesn't
matter they gotta [ __ ] leave anyway
and it's fine
okay I want to actually go on record I
know I say this all the time
well I love
[ __ ] Canada and I say it all the time
but I love Canada it's so nice people
are so friendly they were raised right
and when I go to Canada every time I'm
like why's everybody in America so
shitty and then I come back to America
and I go like this yeah I fit right in I
fit right in
we got this dog we rescued and we may
keep it I'm not sure about that but we
may keep it we may not but he's a great
dog and we love Him I'm a column chen's
oh and he's skittish a little bit
because he was running around in the
valley without a coat on and it was cold
doesn't eat dog food the guy's
highfalutin man whoever had him before
was [ __ ] for sure like cooking him
blue apron or some [ __ ] because he won't
eat dog food and then whenever I'm
eating anything he's just like all of a
sudden is a trick dog on his hind legs
and um I go so you know what the [ __ ]
going on then do it oh so you know
what's up so if you know what's up then
why you trying to [ __ ] [ __ ] inside
and run away when the doors open that
kid will [ __ ] bolt he will bolt dude
workers leave the door open and he just
goes he won't his ass goes in the air
and then pew and nobody could catch him
right he's quick as [ __ ] man um I want
to play this which is a video that I saw
a long time ago and I always wanted to
[ __ ] IO and I think about it quite a
bit and it's very funny to me and the
other good thing is whenever I put my
[ __ ] forearm on this table the wood
between the between the wood and the
iron it pinches the hair of it and it
really pisses me off and that's a good
thing just so everybody knows I'm so
glad that that happens because it's
[ __ ] why wouldn't I be glad I love
when somebody [ __ ] pulls this [ __ ]
out of anyway Magma ODIs it's called
magma otis and my favorite thing here is
in parentheses best live performance
okay it's not but also in a way it is
this guy's singing is the way I want to
say first of all
he's [ __ ] wearing just something that
the bad guys in Superman would wear with
Christopher Reeves movie and his hair is
has zero product in it which is the best
when somebody has zero product in their
hair it's [ __ ] goddamn hilarious you
have to bro are you in this society put
some product in your hair okay because
you literally look like you [ __ ]
stuck one of his 1975 fingers into an
outlet and then when let's perform this
video how funny is it that this video is
so loud the way they uploaded it I have
to put on the bottom [ __ ] the the
little the littlest volume otherwise
it's too loud oh wow this screenshot
screenshot is [ __ ] amazing
look at this busting it have been
testing Darius I don't want specially
laugh so much but
[Music]
and every time he takes the microphone
away he goes I guess sin daily assertive
lujo busting every time he takes a
microphone away he busts in his pants a
little bit he busts in his [ __ ]
Superman outfit Oh busting dude dude he
for this is a tribute to Otis Redding
right this song is a tribute to Otis
Redding that this [ __ ] French got
what is this legendary singer Christian
Vander killing it annoys what is he
German what is this who knows it's a
like legendary singer Christian Vande or
killing it Christian van are bringing me
to tears singing a made-up language
about aliens and [ __ ] this is sublime is
it not a real [ __ ] language Wow he's
French
[Music]
I want to be I want to sing like this
and I will eye-fuck it's so awesome
this guy's pure him he's pure him that's
why I that's why was talk about you got
to get to the point where you're so you
that it's unreal it's a him no wow look
at him older that's [ __ ] serious in
de leus that is so [ __ ] sin de leus
he's 71 right now you know that makes me
think hora hora sin Darius these guys
saw him
well you deserve so many [ __ ] for
real let's go on because when you go on
this really kicks it up into high gear
[Music]
yeah
Oh
[Music]
Wow I've never been in love with a man
before but I'm in love with him for real
that is [ __ ] Cindy
[Music]
just really liked her a lot
Wow
bro as in the area
this has to be a real [ __ ] let's look
at the comments out some of the stuck
that landing wide let me look at what he
does it and stuck that landing
[Music]
or people clapping I guess oh wow
somebody writes so ugly and yet so
beautiful to see that's the best thing
that's the best dude when something's
bad and good it's absolutely the best it
is absolutely the best I always [ __ ]
say this that's why coffee is the best
because it's not good but I keep
drinking it every day for some reason
waiting for it to be good and it's also
kind of in a way good that's why I like
dumb silly humor because it's good and
also bad but that's what makes it good
yeah we don't need to [ __ ] do any
other thing anymore yeah I got faint
when I did that um anyway dude Sindel
eeeh for real it's amazing yeah you got
Twitter questions I thought you said you
did and fired yes one fire yes dude in
the recess in the notes I have dude [ __ ]
yeah I love when people have seven days
to delete something but do it makes my
part yes dude we have dinner face yes
ass in D'Elia know I get why you listen
to this and you don't listen to NPR do
it look at this how I did that look at
how I did this how I caught the [ __ ]
pen dude my name is Daniel Kim so that's
what's up
I don't know I guess we could wrap it up
nah whatever dude
we could wrap it up it doesn't matter
you guys let's just chill for a little a
you know what is the truth I love you
guys for listening to this thank you it
really makes me so happy and I'm
genuinely thankful for you guys we
covered a lot of things today we covered
how much I like Canada we covered
Orillia we covered how nice Canadians
are we covered my [ __ ] imbecile
opener who forgot his passport to try
and go to another country we talked
about conduct ourselves and we talked
about a lot of other things too Aaron
Hernandez documentary just recap in you
know just recapping that's it
not now do I want to [ __ ] restore my
Mack not now that's it dude you guys
were great
so listen you guys I also want to say in
a very real note it is the three-year
anniversary it is the three year
anniversary for congratulations podcast
and I wouldn't be able to do this
podcast well I would be able to do this
podcast without you guys but it would be
just me walking around this room not
being filmed and not being audio and
just talking to myself
talking myself into oblivion and madness
but because of you guys I'm able to do
what I do and be even happier about it
because I know people are out there
listening and I also know it's helping
my bag situation but thank you for your
some of you guys have been here since
the first episode some of you guys have
listened since the first episode and are
still listening 156 episodes later and
guess what you're gonna listen to the
157th some of you guys started on the
60th some of you guys this is your first
episode but what I want to say is
whether you're a long time listener or
whether you've even listened just once
thank you it's been three years and it's
honestly changed my life it's made my
life better this podcast it's helped my
material on stage it's made me a better
comedian and I genuinely I know a lot I
talked a lot of [ __ ] and I'm often
very silly but I genuinely appreciate
you guys listening and all the artwork
you send me and all the tweets and all
the the crazy DMS that people write like
you know [ __ ] me in the mouth or
whatever it is you know because your dad
died early I really truly appreciate all
the craziness the tattoos the life flips
tattoos the Eagle tattoos the CUDA
tattoos you guys are all [ __ ]
absolutely insane and out to lunch for
this cult and one day we will all be
sitting in a log cabin that we built in
tall grass [ __ ] and sucking
and sharing ideas because that's what's
important we advanced this society and
we advanced the babies we the babies you
out there listening right now you baby
you helped advance society and you will
help advance this cult in a very
positive way so keep [ __ ] and sucking
let's get to four years let's get to
five years and that's probably it
because I hope to be a big action movie
star by then but it doesn't matter I'll
probably still do the [ __ ] podcast
because I need you babies as much as
almost as much as you need me at me
right almost [ __ ] and sucking since
day one [ __ ] and sucking since day
one and Nats from the lonely boy thank
you oh also [ __ ] download the cash up
for free on App Store or Google Play
market alright you know cuz bags and you
can text me at eight one eight two three
nine seventy eighty seven and I'll be in
[ __ ] West Palm Beach soon
Robinson Ville Mississippi for some
reason soon throne of Park California
cuz some reason soon Bray and Las Vegas
get the new merch life riffs got a
surprise for you keep checking my
website it's gonna be a restock and
there's gonna be more new [ __ ] almost
love you guys and thank you
[Music]